[Music]
on today's show we talked to an
expecting mom who wants a daughter but
she's having a son we talked to a woman
whose brother-in-law's moving in to her
home and her new marriage we talk to a
guy who's dealing with family trauma and
needs to separate from his parents stay
tuned
[Music]
happy new years what's up this is john
with the dr john deloney's show
it's 2022.
and what's so weird is we may already be
dead but we've recorded this show
and it's out into the ether
whatever is gonna happen at the end of
21 has already happened by the time this
is out
i don't know if that's weird but if
you're on psychedelics right now this
just got to be an incredibly dope show
but
from probably most of you aren't most of
you are like getting your kids ready for
school or whatever because this isn't
we're just not that cool of a show so
i'm so glad you're with us if you want
to be on the show we talk about mental
health relationships
about dealing with trauma about
what in the world's going on with school
and politics is mad whatever's going on
and the madness in your universe we're
here to walk alongside you
um
i'd love you to be on the show
johndaloney.com
ask fill out the form it goes to kelly
she decides if you can be on the show or
not
and
you can give us a shout if you want to
call leave a message old school 1985
style
1-844-693-3291 that's
six nine 1-844-693 three two nine one
happy new year's james
happy new year john
so that sounds like you meant it i did i
as much as i can mean it for the fact
that it's not even december yet when
we're recording so crazy we're speaking
into the future
murray did you get everything you wanted
for christmas
i did i got that new car with the bow on
top
that's so weird i don't even know if i
got what i wanted for christmas yet but
we have to pretend
oh well that's cool let's go to abby in
montgomery alabama what's up abby how we
doing
you're doing well how are you remarkable
hey you got to hear me botch the intro
the first time
it's cool man yes i did
i hope it makes the final cut i assure
you it won't
um james isn't that kind of producer but
it will make the
that is true i'm not that kind of it
wasn't great so what's up abby how can i
help
hey well um so
i guess the short question is i found
out last week that we are having another
boy um this will be our last pregnancy
because i have some medical
complications between the first and the
second one
and i was just kind of wondering how to
process the fact that
i'm not going to have a girl and all
that entails um i'm really
excited about another boy i'm much
better at being a boy mom then i feel
like i would be a girl mom and
everything that i'm kind of like
processing right now is stuff that won't
happen for the next 20 years
but it kind of hit me hard like last
week when i guess because i didn't know
that i
wanted a girl but then again like i'm
really happy that i have a boy too so
yeah
how many can we do that well number one
that just turned four
did you get one just turn four and then
this is number two
yep i'm 18 weeks along so can we just
celebrate for a second way to go
congratulations way to go i mean that's
awesome this is a miracle baby for sure
because we had a lot of medical
complications in between the first and
the second one very cool
and so when you i hear people say i wish
i had a girl and it's a 20-year
thought
the idea being girls just
daughters take care of their parents
better than sons do is that your
thinking
yes
so i'm one of four i'm one of four i
have two brothers and and one sister and
without a doubt i can
yes
all right i have some thoughts on that
but we'll say that for a second
um
let me write a note to myself
so
how much of this like
what's in your soul right now
is pregnancy related versus gender
related here's what i mean by that
i haven't not met a woman yet and i know
they exist and so don't be mean to me on
the internets women
but most of the women all the women i've
met
there's even if they've got kid five
kids seven whatever
the day they decide this is it it's hard
this is a hard it's it's a hard season
or is this no
like this is all about i wish i had a
daughter
i'm gonna go with probably just wish i
had a daughter i am uh
in my friend group we joke that i'm the
least maternal
person in the group like most moms are
like oh i can't i don't want my babies
to leave and i'm like i'm training these
kids to go out like
bye so
i think it's just the fact that i love
your training the ones not even born yet
you're like already
i mean
i love it
yes it's just all right so
i will say i can't speak into this
directly because i've
never
been pregnant
um what i can speak into is this i did
have a picture of what my family would
look like
and i don't even know where that picture
came from it's probably one of the
pictures i was born into which is my
culture said this is about how many kids
you should have
and by the way weirdly this is what they
should look like nobody ever said this
is what your kid should look like but
there's just enough pictures about kit
looking of kids that
i just start to think this is what they
should look like
and then there was pictures in my head
of like me and my
girlfriend at the time and now why for
other girlfriends i had or my parents or
brothers and sisters like we just talked
about it
the family i have now looks very
different than the ones that were in my
pictures they were in the stories
and
it sounds like a weird thing a weird
word but i'm just taking it back
you got to just grieve what you thought
was gonna happen
and what you hoped for was gonna happen
and that didn't happen right
right and then
most stop there i'm just gonna wallow in
it and you know i know there are moms
bajillions of them and dads who blame
their kid
let them know i always wanted a girl or
you were the accident or you were that
whatever
um my little brother still refers to
himself as the
the great accident right
i'm not a mistake so i mean i i can
there you go there's 17 years between me
and my oldest brother
i see it i i i hate that that's in your
soul you know what i mean and it is yeah
they told you that and you can do math
you know how math works
mostly my siblings telling me that my
mom and dad though
exactly siblings are brutal
all i can say is this i want to give you
permission
to
go i want a girl
and i'm not gonna have one i'm not gonna
have old dresses
i'm not gonna have pigtails
i'm not going to whatever like whatever
the thing is unless your boys have
pigtails that's your boys your dresses
and that's another call for another show
um but like i'm not gonna have that i'm
not gonna have when they get older i'm
gonna have to deal with my boys and not
whatever i want you to grieve that okay
you have permission to sit down and be
sad about that
not forever not worth stability but sit
down and own that that could look like
you
writing a letter to yourself
or to the daughter you're not going to
have
or
to your future whatever so whatever that
looks like however you need to agree
that i want you just to take some time
and own it what does your husband think
did he want a daughter too
he wanted a daughter from the first baby
so he um
yeah he's he's always wanted a girl but
we just
our families pretty much just have boys
so
i mean it wasn't surprising but it was
just kind of like kind of hit me all
it's all at once like
all these things down the road that are
just like not gonna happen and so do it
worry about being clingy to
like when they finally do leave and
not being
a good mother-in-law when they get
married and things like that so okay so
i want you and your husband to agree
that together
make it a thing
and talk about it out loud
the secret that you wished that your son
had been his daughter
will haunt him
don't do that to him speak it let it out
by not speaking it we think we're hiding
it and we're getting away with it we're
not
then the second thing is this
raise your boys to be hospitable and to
love their parents
and to be people of character and to
notice things and to take care
you have an opportunity to train them
into what love looks like demonstrably
and you have a
one of my wife's grand plans
is to teach our son
how to pick
a spouse that
like is is good as a good person
she wants to she's got a picture in her
head where she and her daughter-in-law
are
are friends they're connected at some
like they get get along they are
a part of the same gang
and i
think that's those conversations start
early
with how do you pick girlfriends and how
do you pick you know how do you pick
somebody who's a that you're
romantically interested in how does it
how do you do all that
you get to speak into that
and the meta here for me is this you're
worrying about stuff that's not going to
happen for decades
i know
is that just you how you roll
yes that is 100
like one small thing happens in my
brains you know 10 20 30 years down the
road going oh man
you're gonna miss out on a lot of life
living like that
yeah
and so can i
offer you one more piece of wisdom
you get to choose this sounds crazy you
get to choose your thoughts
you get to choose them
now we don't get to choose the lightning
bolts the ones that pop in our head the
one that's
we're not gonna have a daughter
and then it pops in oh my gosh i'm gonna
be taken care of
when i'm old by two idiot boys you can't
stop that one
the next thought is on you
the next thought to go
oh my gosh then what's gonna happen and
then i need to start planning for this
one all of that is you it's a choice
and it's something that we practice and
over time those default settings the
down the spirals the 20 years oh my gosh
what's going to hap
all of that stuff you practice you
choose i'm not going to go down that
road anymore i'm not going to try to
control 20 years from now i'm going to
make good choices today i'm going to
follow the process and then in 20 years
i'm going to do what's going on 20 years
i'm going to save my money today i'm
going to teach my boys how to love i'm
gonna show them how to love i'm gonna
show them
via loving their dad
i'm gonna i'm gonna make it so hard the
picture they have
what an awesome wife
what an awesome partner it is
i'm gonna show them so much our marriage
is gonna be so good that those boys are
gonna be like oh my gosh they're gonna
set the bar high and you and your
husband's gonna live that out like man
you get to decide all that and then 20
years from now they bring home some
knucklehead solve that then right
okay enjoy your life now but going back
to the original thing
i'm giving you permission to be sad
okay
giving you permission you and your
husband go out get breakfast together go
to cracker barrel and eat too much and
be sad about it and then
you're gonna have to work out hard to
get rid of that nonsense that you just
tortured your body and
i want y'all to be about
loving this little boy
recklessly loving this little boy let
this little boy know that he is a
miracle
like our family would not be the same
without him
i mean you got an adventure ahead ahead
of you and i'm excited for you we'll be
right back on the dr john delaney show
[Music]
hey what's up this delony let's talk
about getting a good night's sleep it's
important for your physical health your
mental health your relation health for
your sanity you name it sleep is
important if you're not sleeping good
one of the first questions i want you to
ask is do i need a new mattress
here's how you tell are you tossing and
turning all night because you can't get
comfortable are you waking up in the
middle of the night burning hot or in
the morning does your back hurt if you
have any of these issues you may need a
new mattress
check out dream cloud it's a mattress i
have in my own house you will love it
and they're currently running their
biggest offer of all time
400 bucks in accessories plus an
additional 250 discount only for delony
listeners that's a total of 650 bucks in
accessories and savings visit
dreamcloudsleep.com deloney or
dreamcloudsleep.com
and enter promo code deloney to get a
new mattress shipped to your house today
and you can enjoy 650 bucks in savings
that's
dreamcloudsleep.com promo code
d-e-l-o-n-y
all right we are back we're staying in
alabama let's go to tiffany in
huntsville hey what's up tiffany
hey john how's it going we are partying
how about you
busy day taking a little moment off from
work good for you good for you if you
want to let's take a long moment we can
just make this call 50 minutes you can
curl up under the desk we can just chit
chat sound good
okay sounds good excellent so what's up
so
my husband and i got married in january
and
here recently my mother-in-law has
decided that she is moving back to
oregon and she has a 37 year old
son who she is
not necessarily
you know kicking us you know kicking
them our way but um
placing us in charge of his care
um
so
nothing that is diagnosed
that we have paperwork for or nothing
that we have um
any medical
understanding of honestly and that is
where we've
fell in this really awkward position of
do we treat him like an adult or do we
treat him like
he has some sort of special needs
they
are under the
impression that he has high functioning
autism he has a job
as a security person for a bank
but
he is not
functioning
as far as his finances he is
very unstable he does very frivolous
things he can barely
pay for his food he lives with us we
actually bought a huge house so that we
could enable him because i do have two
kids as well so um
there's there's a lot to it but we don't
know how to move forward without
hindering
the rest of our marriage or without um
like we want we want to help them but we
don't we also don't want to
further enable him like he has been for
the last 37 years if you know if if he
is just an enabled individual who has
an excuse essentially yeah
so here's
how long have you been married
nine ten oh eleven months
your marriage is in trouble isn't it
you're tired you're you're tired already
no we're we're definitely not tired we
not we what about you
i'm not i'm
i have a very toxic family history so
i'm
this is nothing this is easy 37 year old
dude move in we're good okay well we
we have a we bought a whole house and we
have a whole house full of people um we
we enable veterans to live with us and
that's a whole different situation but
um
but with him it is a very much a
we don't know
and we don't have the tools to know if
there's a way of going about
do we get him medically diagnosed
and how does that look like or do we
enable him to be an
adult and then look at the possibility
of him continuing on these really
negative
patterns with his finances and then us
going through and having to deal with
the repercussions of his brother not
financially taking care of himself
and being young in our marriage you know
that that would be a lot for us to
handle that's right
so whether he has special needs or not
you and your husband have to decide we
are not going to participate
in him living a less than life
and his parents his mom's dad whoever
has
facilitated in him either not getting
the care that he needs to be successful
the accommodations the mental health
care the physical care the physical
therapy the training that he needs
or
which i think is borderline abusive
or
they have just allowed a child
to morph and
slovenly grow into a 37 year old
dependent
right either way you'll have to decide
we're out of that game
so that's that's where it becomes
really difficult on us because his mom
is so hey here's the deal it's not
difficult it's not difficult got it it's
hard but it's not difficult
right okay
mom's out of the picture now she doesn't
get a vote she doesn't get a choice
she's moving
right so her
her influence here is over completely
done
and if she's giving money i'd give her
money back
it's not worth it you moved
you dropped your 37 year old challenge
on us
fine you're done
we are people who practice hospitality
as a way of life that's who you and your
husband are you serve veterans you serve
those in your community you got your own
kids
great
mom's out
and she can kick and scream and he need
your husband needs to to
suck it up and have a hard conversation
with mom my guess is he doesn't have
that conversation
we've had we recently over the weekend
had a conversation with her that
it's either
one path or the other he's either
disabled and we're going to take
guardianship over him
and that's going to be the end because
he's reached a point that he's morbidly
obese like in he's using his depression
to
enable him further in doing death
threats towards his mom and she had a
child commit suicide 10 years ago so
she's already in a very difficult spot
which makes it harder for us to
to be the the hard love in the family
but
listen listen somebody has to stop the
madness and it sounds like it was a
trauma
trauma-filled home is that fair
yes
your husband grew up in in hell really
right
yes yeah and
there's probably all kinds of physical
and psychological things going on with
brother
yeah
what y'all can do is you can't save him
he's got to have to make some choices at
some point what you can do is put him in
a position to be successful and that
starts exactly the conversation you had
and you all had the initial one and now
you're gonna have a putting your foot
down one
either we are gonna become guardians of
somebody with special with an adult with
special needs we're gonna get all the
resources that we need along those lines
we're gonna get him the the health care
that he needs that you mom have not
gotten him for 37 freaking years
for whatever reason i don't blame her i
don't know what her world was like who
knows
what we're dealing with was today
and
he's gonna have to be a part of some
solutions what he has to understand is
sitting at home
and just continuing to slowly take his
own life
is not an option
and that might mean that he packs up and
leaves y'all
and you'll have to be prepared for that
but he's a 37 year old man
we would we would be
we would be okay with that um
oh thank god that'd be great yeah yeah
yeah our fear i mean our just our fear
with that is that you know he has had
his own house for or his own apartment
for a stint and she just came over and
did his laundry and she made sure his
bills were paid and it's just and
if he were to leave the house at this
point then we would be concerned that he
wouldn't make those things happen
because he has a massive internet
addiction
as well that of course i mean he's he
spent over 30 000 in the last year just
on
things that he shouldn't be and
and
we're at a loss
here's the thing he is
in the ocean
waving his arm for help
and the people who love him just keep
putting their foot on his head
right
and that just gets to stop with y'all
okay you have to know
taking a 37 year old who has been babied
in this way or neglected in this way
either one of those two things
is going to be
incredibly hard to change
agreed
real real hard
and you throw in major depression you
throw in internet addiction you throw in
loneliness you throw in mom's enabling
nonsense you throw in obesity you're
talking
the the
comorbid effects here are powerful
exponential they're hard
and it's a long haul
real long hauls i'm just painting a
realistic picture this is not going to
be like a real good hard weekend
conversation
you're talking about some major shifts
can he do it you're i'm telling you
right now you can absolutely
do anything he wants to
right but what i want you and your
husband to do is to
get away together go have a long meal
and i say this all the time but go get a
long meal and you become resolute
together
absolutely you all get lockstep this is
what our triggers will be when he's out
you're moving out of our house i don't
care where you're going
or
you're gonna go to get this psychiatric
workup you're gonna go get an aba work
up you're gonna go do whatever we like
get a physical workup or you're gone
you're out of our home because we're not
gonna participate in your death
absolutely that that totally makes sense
is that cool and then you and your
husband are on the same page there's no
mix signals there's no well i thought we
were doing this nope we have outlined
this sucker
absolutely
we're this the same way with most things
in life so that that totally
i love it
i
yeah just the the
the gross abuse that's been done to this
man it just sucks
we just don't want to continue on the
same road for the next 40 years of our
life absolutely yeah of course and hey
how old are your kids
uh there's six and eight they're gonna
watch every second of this
absolutely every second and by the way
you grew up in a hard home too
yes absolutely you and your husband got
your own trauma work do you all got to
deal with is that fair
oh yes
will you commit to that
well i have i i mean we're both veterans
so we're both
more both in therapy so okay we're good
but you're committed to it
absolutely so good
so good
can i just back out 30 000 feet and just
look at you in the eyes even though
we're on the internets here i'm talking
on the phone i just tell you i'm
grateful for you
well thank you our community needs more
people like you in it
thank you i appreciate that and finding
that balance between hospitality and
enabling is hard that's a hard line to
walk when do you give somebody a meal
and when you give somebody a kick in the
booty and say go get them right that's
hard
and you all navigate that every day by
inviting people into your home fair
absolutely yeah well i'm i'm so grateful
most people sit there spend their whole
life on the sidelines and you have
chosen to get in the messy middle of
that but that does not work
if the two captains aren't well right
absolutely got it
yes you're gonna love this knuckleheaded
husband of yours till the wheels fall
off
yes you're gonna dedicate y'all's lives
to each other
absolutely and you're gonna not lose
intimacy because your house is loud and
crazy
i know
[Laughter]
yes i love it
i love uh no uh no
no and you're gonna love those two
little ones
absolutely and you're not gonna let that
37 year old just
die
no we're not good
the world needs more people like tiffany
thank you so much for being the person
that you are i'm grateful grateful
grateful for you now you got a mission
you got a new mission you had one in the
service and now you got a new one
and it is rad good for you
strength
day after day same page clarity
working through it so grateful for you
tiffany hey walk with oh i'll walk with
you let's just say you walk with me i'll
walk with you call me back after you'll
have these hard conversations i'd love
to know how the doctor appointment works
out if he chooses to go i'd love to know
how mom comes
hollering back
because it's going to happen i want to
know how all that goes because we're
going to walk alongside you as you make
some major changes in your lives
and as you get this brother
of yours and your husbands
on his two own two feet again
[Music]
and change every square inch of his life
2022 is going to be big for tiffany and
family we'll be right back on the dr
john delaney show
you all know there are lots of things
that make me nuts but one thing makes me
more nuts than anything else
buying a home and my friends who
refinance their homes they tell me it
makes them nuts too
i love living in a new home but i gotta
be honest i'm no good at buying one and
that's why i'm so thankful for people
like my friends at churchill mortgage
churchill is a ramsey trusted provider
who we've been sending people to for
over 20 years to help with home
mortgages why
because they're committed to doing
what's right for you and that means
walking you through paperwork that's way
over your head that means making sure
you get the right mortgage that you can
pay off as soon as possible and they'll
try to upsell you a bunch of nonsense
that's going to hurt you down the road
and most importantly when you're making
this big life change you can actually
breathe because you got an expert in a
team who have your back listen if you're
about to buy a home and make a big
change
save yourself the headache and call
churchill mortgage today at triple h
loan 200. trust me that's triple eight
loan 200.
this is a paid advertisement in mls id
1591 in the mls consumeraccess.org equal
housing lender 1749 mallory lane sweet
100 brentwood tennessee 37027 programs
are for select loan types only and are
not available in all states or locations
all right we are back hey we got a
follow-up email and then we'll get we'll
take one more call
this email is from angela and she was on
the show march 31st 2021 show number 91
and here's what she writes
i called a while back about my 12 year
old daughter in competitive gymnastics
you asked me to contact you and let you
know how things went so i'm doing just
that
and if if you remember i want you to go
back and listen to that call
march 31 2021 episode 91
parents were wondering
how hard do we push our kids in
athletics we don't want them to grow up
to be quitters or be wimps or whatever
but
we also don't want to be those parents
like what's how do we find that balance
she writes it's been quite a few months
since our conversation and things have
changed around here first thing that
happened is my husband and i backed way
off we decided to take things one day at
a time and not bring up
gymnastics at all to our daughter it's
her sport and her story so she could
bring it up to us we would not bring it
up to her
what happened was amazing
she started talking she told us about
the joy and struggles gymnastics gave
her we talked about what she wants from
this sport she came up with a plan and a
goal and we are along for the ride she
decided to go from four days which was
16 to 20 hours a week in the gym to
three days 12 to 14 hours in the gym
per week
she accepted the invitation to join the
new junior high
accelerated math program and took an
elective called social awareness what
math and social awareness you're raising
a laser
social awareness has been an amazing
opportunity for my little planner the
class allows for the students to see
things in school in the community even
in the country that they would like to
change and have or have an impact on and
make it happen
she came up with ideas plans and
executes them and so far the class has
held a hurricane relief supply drive
planned a
trick-or-treat for the kindergarten
class helped read with second graders
and have many more plans in the works
they are doing amazing things i wish
they offered the class all year long
she's happy and talks all the time about
what's going on in her life and what she
wants to do and how she's feeling she's
the only seventh grader i know that
openly hugs her mom in front of the
whole cafeteria before heading off to
class for the day
thank you for your advice angela thank
you
and your husband
for choosing love and connection
over
the scholarship
childhood scholarship program where we
just torture our kids good for you
because here's the thing we we create
this false dichotomy where
either i've got to
dominate and crush and disappoint
on our kids through athletics or
they're going to turn into this slovenly
wimpy character-free knuckleheads
and what you saw here is no she's got a
foundation
and y'all told her you're going to do
something you're going to participate in
some things you got to choose but you're
going to participate you're not going to
come home and do nothing
and then you all backed off and let this
seventh grader that you all have raised
to be hard-working in a person of
character
you let her begin to speak into her
story not by herself cause she's in
seventh grade she's too young to be
writing her own story
but she handed her the pen and then
y'all said some guide rails
and wouldn't you know it she joined the
math club the accelerated math program
who
gosh i would have tried to join that
program and they would have said here's
a fun game get out
and she's
serving your community she's still
working hard in physical activity good
for you guys good for you guys good for
you guys and the most important thing
here
is you have created an environment where
she trusts you
and she's talking to you and when she
does something dumb which she will do
you are gonna be the first person she
thinks to contact you're creating a
system of trust in your home
good for you good for you good for you
and for everybody out there i'm all
about athletics
i make my kid my kids have to
participate they have to move their body
it's a that's a part of life
i think competition teaches incredible
lessons it's a gift they got to work
hard they have to work as a team they
got to see that you put in the work
today for results tomorrow that all
that's important
and
i'm not living vicariously through my
kid
their victory is not my victory their
loss is not my laws
it's both hand it's both and
all right let's take one more call let's
go to eli in albany new york what's up
eli
dr d thank you for taking my call i
appreciate it you got it brother what's
up man uh it's an honor to talk to you
thank you so now to talk to you i was i
was afraid this was gonna be eli manning
he's always trying to call in to get on
the show
like man i'm not gonna talk to another
quarterback former quarterback for nfl i
can't let it go thank god it's not it's
you eli so cool what's up
uh well i'm trying to decide whether i
should um split talking to my parents
all right so tell me about it
well um so my parents moved out of out
of the area from where i live a while
ago
and um
we've had a pretty turbulent
relationship you know through my teen
years and uh what is that growing up
what does that mean um
well my my parents split when i was a
young teen my father was uh
was
he had a hard time he was a bipolar i
think i mean he was never diagnosed but
you know
physically and and verbally abusive
and so my they separated and then i
tried to form a relationship with my dad
while they were separated when i moved
out and started my life they wound up
getting back together
i was the youngest of uh three
biological
and
they moved away
and it was always a little bit strange
it was a little bit off
you know my parents tend to really kind
of talk about themselves and what's
going on with themselves
and we're never really too concerned
about what's going on with us
and a couple years ago
i have uh
some adopted brothers and
one of my brothers passed away
and when we went to go see him
my parents were acting a little strange
about it and they wound up
getting arrested for
for
my the wrongful death of my brother
and they wound up going to to jail
while the court case was going on and
i wrote a couple letters but i never i
never mailed them i just
it was just so much it was so much i
i
when i spoke to my dad he wasn't honest
about what had happened so i i didn't
know what to do i wrote some letters i
never i never mailed them they wrote
some letters to me i never opened them i
still just have them put away and when
they came out of
when they came out of jail they wound up
settling and and doing you know parole
and
and all this stuff but it was
what was fractured got even worse
they kind of felt betrayed by me
and so now my
my older two siblings don't speak to
them at all at all and have no problem
with it
and i just feel so guilty like uh like i
i want to try and honor my parents and i
know you say always choose guilt over
resentment yeah or choose uh that's
right
you know i
every time i try i tried setting
boundaries like look let's not talk
about my siblings i'm calling you
because i want you to have relation with
me and my my children
but they don't have a relationship with
my children i tried putting them on the
phone to talk to my children and they
didn't really
care to
my mom still says my youngest daughter's
name improperly
and how old are you brother
i am 41.
did your parents
kill your younger brother
i
i believe that
they were older and neglect
that they
made mistakes
always with a
all of your language brother
somehow
some
some way
you became the person who apologizes for
your parents
you're the person that makes sure
that the world knows i know but there's
this other thing i i i know but that
that's been your job and it may have
been with your siblings
may have been with your community may
have been in your own home when dad was
raged out
and
you're explaining it away to brothers
and sisters whatever
i need you to hear me say eli
it's not your job
the stories that you're born into you're
born into some hard stories
about what love looks like about what
parents are supposed to look like
about what blame connection looks like
all those things
and you were told some crappy stories
too about what you were worth what your
job was all that stuff
and somehow over
happens to all of us
the stories you're born into the stories
you were told have become the stories
you tell yourself this is my job i've
got to do this i've got to do this i
have to do that
and eli let me free you from it brother
it's not your job
what i want you to do is to live in the
reality that your parents
um
they weren't hurting who you needed them
to be
can you own that
yes
can you say that i want you to say that
out loud
my parents
weren't what i needed them to be
and they continue to not be what i need
them to be
and they continue to not be what i need
them to be and i need you to sit in that
for a minute because that is reality
that's reality they don't care to even
you learn your daughter's name
they got out of jail
after neglectfully contributing to the
death of one of your brothers and blamed
you for your attitude
and somehow being the young brother
being the guy in the middle whatever the
thing is this is all compressed like a
like a vertebrae in your
soul that this is your responsibility
and brother it's not
tell me about your kids
i have four amazing kids how old are
they my oldest
uh 12
10
8 and six dude incredible man
boys girls
uh i have three girls and a boy my
oldest ah you're in it now
my oldest reminds me so much of of my
mom in the sense that she's creative and
she loves to make things and she likes
knit and cookie art and
i've always i always felt like if i just
tried hard enough i could i could make
the connection for my kids
you can't
and i hate to be the guy that tells you
that here's the thing you know that but
i want to also
high five you man and i'd hug you if
you're standing here
because you've been working hard to find
any
way possible
to connect with two people
who should have connected with you from
day one and they didn't
and it's not your job not only is it not
your job you can't do it
it's like trying to plug uh out like a
like an extension cord into a wall if
there's no plug there man there's
nowhere for it to go
and you've been working so hard
and your kids became
um
they became your lifeline maybe if one
of my kids kind of like maybe that'll be
and again you're just grabbing different
extension cords trying to shove it in
the same wall there's no plug over there
man
your kids won the lottery getting you as
their dad do you hear me say that
yes your childhood was hard wouldn't it
yes you're a tough new yorker
and you know what things you say out
loud and what things stay inside our
house i get that
your childhood's hard right
yeah you experienced some stuff
yeah yeah
yeah are your kids going to experience
any of that nonsense
no no no we have a we have a happy home
i have a wonderful wife
a great you know great church community
i've had people step in
to to
be that older you know other people who
are like grandparents yes
now you got you got one last person
eli
and you have made your life's mission
making sure your wife is loved and
making sure those kids do not experience
anything like what you went through
and you've done the hard gut-wrenching
work of replacing parents who left you
spiritually and psychologically they
showed up and i actually think there's
some there's some pretty compelling work
that suggests that's more damaging makes
things kids makes kids think they're
nuts they're crazy because mom and dad
are in the house but mom and dad are
violent her mom and dad are
nuts or they're loud or they neglectful
and it's easier if a kid just if
someone's separate sometimes that's a
whole other call though
you've made everybody else a priority my
brother and that is noble
and good and right
the last person you gotta deal with is
eli
is that guy worthy of love
yes
you don't believe that though man
i i feel
i feel like uh
everything you're saying is 100 spot-on
irrational and yet there's this part of
me that feels like a failure that i
can't fix that that's it that's it
that's what i'm telling you you gotta
unhook from that
here's the you know the letter i want
you to write
is to seven-year-old eli
cuz that kid experienced
bull crap
and that eli is still trying to get mom
and dad to love him
and 41 year old eli has a lot bigger
body you're a lot hairier
you know you're not like an albany dude
like a big thick gold chain are you
uh yeah that's me oh my gosh
all right i'll give it to you so you're
just strutting through albany big chain
everything
seven-year-old eli still driving
still asking
why don't they like
me yeah why won't he just sit down and
say i'm proud of you boy
why won't she just grab both sides of my
face and give me a grody kiss on my
forehead and say i love you eli why
won't they do that
and so
you're going to make yourself crazy
trying to solve that question because
it's not yours to solve go ahead brother
i'm sorry so one like they called like
they called for my birthday
uh this past birthday i had in october
to let me know
that they were splitting up
like they called on my birthday to tell
me that i mean do i just like not answer
the phone not answer texts put them on
call block i know
and how does it practically look
you tell me do i do is there a
confrontation
you tell me
it sounds like your your older siblings
went with the no contact route
yes i don't want you all in our life
fair
that's the boundary they had to draw for
whatever reason and maybe they
experienced more nonsense more evil than
you did
who knows
or they have whatever they didn't feel
like it was their responsibility to heal
um
dysfunctional
um
hurting older people they just said dude
we're gonna live our lives
if you can hear that get that kind of
phone call and roll your eyes and be
like cool happy birthday to y'all too
and you can hang up and smile and be
like my gosh and move on great
if you can't don't
i'm not going to set your boundaries for
you is what i'm saying
yeah i don't believe in ghosting
i think there is something profound and
strong about being clear and simple
and direct
with
hey mom y'all don't even know my
daughter's name
y'all don't even visit you called to
tell me about your divorce on my
birthday
you all demonstrate
all have better things going on in your
life than me and my four incredible kids
y'all's lost not ours
and i wish you all the best
and that's the end of that conversation
no explaining no that
simple
clear facts are your friends appeared at
the end of the sentence
or okay you know what i'm saying like
and dude you got to grieve the bloody
hell out of this
because you've never sat down and said
this might like you've been propping up
this myth for so long
and you you thought that you thought the
myth was your responsibility to make
sure it all worked
yeah
it's not your responsibility is making
sure those four kids are loved your
responsibility is making sure your wife
is honored and loved your responsibility
is making sure you're loved
and that you're well absolutely and that
you're whole is that fair
yes you take care of your body get a
smaller chain brother for real and
but you know i mean like that's what you
were responsible for
yeah
and you're responsible for your own
healing
and that starts with stop stop
reinjuring yourself stop allowing
yourself to be cut and cut and cut okay
but i can't make your boundaries for you
my my recommendation is have you ever
sat down to ask your wife what her dream
boundary would be
um my wife would prefer that i didn't
talk to my parents because whenever i do
i feel terrible after listen to your
wife
that woman loves you
she chose you out of all the
knuckleheads with big chains walking up
and down the eastern seaboard she chose
you
yeah right and often yeah if we if we
find a good partner they they see our
blind spots better than we do
yeah absolutely
and there may come a time brother when
you've healed enough that you can enter
back into that
blizzard
of nonsense and be fine
but maybe it's just not right now maybe
you need a break for a couple years to
heal make sure you are on two solid feet
and then you are anchored into your new
community to your family to your friends
in that area
to the guys that come over and help you
fix your car at 10 o'clock after the
kids are in bed yeah you know what i
mean you know john it feels like i i had
done that where i separated i went
through a program called subway recovery
i went through a lot of the heal in the
past
it's like it's like they have it's like
they know the back door codes no of me
you've kept a back door open
close it
don't give them that power eli they
don't have it they only have that power
because you keep handing it to them
you haven't changed the code
and that code changing that code is hard
and it might mean i'm blocking you from
everything
or it might mean like you know what i
mean i don't have this if you don't
it can look any number of ways
but you keep you you just keep one line
in the water just in case they bite just
in case that one day they're gonna call
and be like what have we done
we want to meet our four miraculous
grandkids and god almighty
of all the crap we put you through you
turned out to be the most amazing father
a dad that i never could have been to
you for you
and that conversation's not gonna happen
that fair
yeah it's heartbreaking right that's the
hard part yeah that's that's the hard
part
they haven't seen my three of them
before my kids
never met them or hugged them
and that's not a statement about you
it's not a statement about your kids
it's a statement about them
they treated seven-year-old eli that way
because something was going on inside of
them not inside of eli
and your kids will never ever be that
validation for your parents my brother
ever
but i will
and your community will
and your wife will and your friends
will so going back to the very beginning
of this call i told you i needed you to
say out loud yo we're not there for me
you know we're not the parents that i
need i need you to sit in that grief
write another letter
don't mail it there isn't reason to mail
it you're just trying to get it out and
get some perspective create some
distance between you and those feelings
that feel like you're gonna drown
get some perspective some distance there
write your parents a letter about your
four kids tell them what they're missing
our daughter she's an incredible artist
our son is a
he's got a small small gold chain but
he's moving up to the big one soon right
whatever it is don't ever mail it
but let it out
and then i do want you to write a letter
to your younger eli self and let that
boy off the hook man he needs to go play
seven year olds should be having fun
he should be having adventures doing
hard things
not trying to make sure their parents
don't hurt them not trying to make sure
their parents marriage stays together
not trying to make sure their parents
don't kill their younger brother
maybe one of the braver calls i've
received in a long time eli thank you so
much for having the courage to call i'm
grateful for you my brother
so grateful
all right man as we wrap up today's show
let's see here
kelly's out
jenna is running the phones
and i said jenna you get to pick the
song today and this is what she brought
me
taylor swift song from the vault
all too well
10 minute version taylor's version from
the vault
and it's 117 pages long
buckle up audience we're going through
the whole thing
nice try
nice try jenna
taylor who's our neighbor she lives
right over here she writes
i walked to the door with you the air
was cold but something about it felt
like home somehow and i left my scarf
there at your sister's house oh my gosh
is this one of those about the boy
i'd hate to be this boy
and you've still got it in your drawer
even now oh your sweet disposition and
my wide-eyed gaze we're singing in the
car getting lost upstate autumn lee's
falling down like pieces into place and
i can picture it after all these days
dude she's such a good writer i love
she's a poet she's so good
and i know it's long gone the magic's
not here no more and i might be okay but
i'm not fine at all that's a great line
ah
she's so good
because there we are again on that
little town street you almost ran the
red because you were looking over at me
when did my hair i was there remember it
all too well photo album on the counter
your cheeks were turning red used to be
a little kid with glasses and a twin
size bed and your mother telling stories
about you and the t-ball team
you taught me about your past thinking
your future was me
and you were tossing the car keys can we
say the effort i don't think we can say
that on this show
forget the patriarchy
keychain on the ground we were always
skipping town
and i was thinking on the drive down
anytime now he's gonna say it's love
he never called it what it was until we
were dead and gone and buried checked
the balls and came back swearing it's
the same after three months in the grave
and then you wondered where it went to
you as i reached for you but all i felt
was shame and you held my lifeless frame
and i know it's long gone and there was
nothing else i could do and i forget
about you long enough to forget why i
needed to
she's incredible
because there we are again in the middle
of the night why why were we singing
motley crue songs during ballet bands
james we should have been covering
taylor swift this is this is poetry that
would have been our whole sense the
whole set would have been a squad song
we're dancing around the kitchen the
refrigerator light down the stairs i was
there i remember it all too well and
there we are again where nobody had to
know you kept me like a secret but i
kept you like an oath oh my gosh what a
line
you kept me like a secret but i kept you
like an oath she should have been a
songwriter for pantera
song prayer sacred prayer and we'd swear
to remember all too well well maybe we
got lost in translation maybe i asked
for too much but maybe this thing was a
masterpiece till you tore up
running scared i was there i remembered
all too well
you call me up again just to break me
like a promise oh my gosh
so casually cruel in the name of being
honest i'm a crumpled up piece of paper
lying here because i remember it all
they say all's well that ends well but
i'm in a new hell every time you
double-cross my mind gosh
you said if we had been closer in age
maybe it would have been fine and that
made me want to die the idea
you had of me
who was she
a never needy ever lovely jewel that
shine whose shine reflects on you
man
not weeping in a party bathroom some
actress asking me what happened you
that's what happened you
you who charmed my dad with
self-effacing jokes sipping coffee like
you're on a late night show oh my gosh
no wonder she sold a 100 billion records
she's so good
like i'm in the story now now i gotta
see how this thing ends and then he
watched me watch the front door all
night willing you to come and he said
it's supposed to be fun turning 21. oh
my gosh now dad's in on it time won't
fly it's like i'm paralyzed by it i'd
like to be my old self again but i'm
still trying to find it after plaid
shirt days and nights
when you made me your own now you mail
back my things and i walk home alone but
you keep my old scarf from that very
first week because it reminds you of
innocence and it smells like me
dude there's so many one-liners here
this is like a year's worth of tweets
it's like an eminem like
rap battle and a pop song yeah
you can't get rid of it
because you remember it all too well
because there we are again when i loved
you so back before you lost the one real
thing you've ever known it was rare i
was there i remember all too well wind
in my hair you were there you remember
it all down the stairs you were there
i wonder what happened down the stairs i
think we know
you remember it all i was it was rare i
was there i remembered all too well and
i was never good at telling jokes but
the punchline goes i'll get older but
your lovers stay my
age matthew mcconaughey shout out
dang
but when your brooklyn broke my skin and
bones i'm a soldier who's returning half
her weight and did the twin flame bruise
paint you blue just between us did the
love affair maim you two
because in the city's barren cold i
still remember the first fall of snow
and how it glistened as it fell i
remembered all too well just between us
did the love affair maim you all too
well just between us do you remember it
all too well
just between us i remember it
all too well
it was rare
you remember it wind in my hair i was
there
i was there sacred prayer i was there it
was rare you remember it
you've gone this far you may as well
repeat all the refrain can't do all the
repeats but jenna
i was doing this to clown you man i feel
like a changed man
best song ever this is like a like a
novel
this is like
oh my gosh
taylor
i know you're a huge fan of the show and
i know you stuck around to the end of
this one
well done on this song a hundred million
people can't be wrong wow see you soon
on the dr john dolan show